[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS CARTLAND: Welcome to
Google+ Developers Live.
My name is Chris Cartland, and
I'm a developer programs
engineer working on the
Google+ platform.
XIANGTIAN DAI: And I'm Xiangtian
Dai, and I'm a
software engineer for the
Google+ iOS SDK platform.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
Well, thanks for coming
this week.
We're going to talk about
interactive posts on iOS,
which is why we brought our iOS
expert with us this time.
Everything we are going to talk
about is fully documented
at developers.google.com/plus,
and you check
out everything there.
Interactive posts are one of
the really cool features of
Google+ sign in.
It allows you to help bring
users from the Google+ stream
into your application.
And so how you're going to do
that is specify a new type of
share in your application that
has a call to action button
with a special piece of text
that you choose, so that users
have some context about what
they're going to do when they
go to your ap.
So it's a cool type of share.
Xiangtian is going to use the
iOS quick start to demonstrate
how to get this running, and
use interactive posts.
And then I'm going to show you
a real world example with the
fancy on how that looks
in the Google+ stream,
and in their app.
Ready?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yes.
The quick start iOS center is
the faster way to get started
with Google+ iOS SDK.
It is included as part
of Google+ iOS SDK.
So before we start, let's look
at the document to see what
the steps are.
So on our document at
googledevelopers
.google.com/plus, as you can
see, we have a quick start,
and let's go to the iOS part.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And of course,
that's the same place that all
of our other quick starts
are for any
of the other languages.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's right.
So the first step is to
create our project
in Google API console.
Here you can create a project.
This project recognizes your
apps for the Google+ services.
So the first thing you will do
is to enable Google+ API.
CHRIS CARTLAND: RIght, so you
turn on the Google+ API.
The first time you do that, you
need to accept the terms
of services.
But there's also a long list
of other APIs that Google
offers, and you can enable those
just by flipping the
switch there.
XIANGTIAN DAI: So the next
thing is to create an
OS to client ID.
this client ID identifies apps
to the Google+, to the Google
services in particular .
So here we need to put
your product name.
This product name helps to
identify your app to users.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And this is
a user facing string.
So whatever you put here is
something that your users will
see, and should recognize is
you, so that they know who
they're trusting when they
sign in with your app.
XIANGTIAN DAI: And you can also
put on your product logo
and home page URL down there.
So the next thing is to specify
your application type.
The client type is stored
application, and in
our case, for iOS.
Now we're going to input
your bundle ID.
This bundle ID is for your iOS
app bundle, which would be the
same as the bundle ID
in your info page
for the Xcode protect.
In our case, it's
comp.google.googleplussimple.
Note that the same bundle ID
is used to handle URL call
back from other apps to your
browsers, to your app.
So you need to specify the same
string as your URL cap,
your handle.
If your app is already published
in the App Store,
you may also want to put your
App Store ID here, so that if
your app is not yet installed by
user, we can prompt you to
install it if a deep
link has been
activated in a user's post.
We'll have this deep link
enabled for now, and we'll
talk about deep link
a little bit later.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So when we've
done this configuration, this
allows a user to click on a post
in the Google+ stream and
be taken directly into your
application on iOS.
So it's a really good way if
you want people to actually
use your iOS app, and it also
allows Google to direct them
to the app store if
they don't already
have the app installed.
XIANGTIAN DAI: That's right.
Note that this client ID stream
is what you're going to
use to identify your app
to the Google services.
For [INAUDIBLE] string,
we'll use it later.
So here, if you look at the
document, the second step is
to download the quick start app
as part of our iOS SDK and
open its Xcode project.
You can always download this iOS
SDK from this link below.
In our case, I've already
downloaded it into my desktop.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, so you can
either just click the link
to download it, or you can
ask Xiangtian to send it
to you in an email.
XIANGTIAN DAI: That's right.
CHRIS CARTLAND: On
Google Drive.
XIANGTIAN DAI: OK, so here is
the Google+ iOS SDK 1.2.1.
Let's open this folder, and it
has a sample code folder.
Inside you will see your
Xcode project.
Open that, and this is our
quick start simple app.
The first thing we will do, as
we just talked about, is to
replace this client ID stream
with your own client ID as
you're registered in the
Google API console.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So this is the
only change that you have to
make to the sample app after
you've download it.
We could just run it right now,
but we're actually going
to have Xiangtian explain it
a little bit more, because
there's some details
of sharing that you
might want to see.
XIANGTIAN DAI: That's right.
OK, so--
by the way, also, one minor
thing you want to change is
about the URL type.
This has to match
your bundle ID.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Where's
that again?
This is in the--
XIANGTIAN DAI: This is in the
info section for your target.
So in the last column, in the
last sections, URL types.
This register URL, your
app will handle.
CHRIS CARTLAND: OK.
Cool.
XIANGTIAN DAI: So here, now
let's go to the Google+ sample
share view controller
[INAUDIBLE].
This is the file that
handles the sharing.
Let's see.
At first, you're going
to initialize this.
Initialized by setting delegated
to itself, to the
view controller itself.
So basically, in GPP share,
share instance, you'll set
delegate to this view controller
instance self, so
that this view controller will
be able to get notifications
back when a user has posted,
or canceled a post.
Next, you'll see a list
of actions, of verbs.
These are for interactive
posts.
Inside interaction posts,
there's a call to action,
which one labels.
And here we list all possible
actions, or labels, for
demonstration purposes.
But in practice, your app will
pick one action that best fits
your needs.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, So we just
listed all of the options
for the call to action button.
You will want to pick whichever
one is most
meaningful for your app, so if
your app has something that
people can buy, when someone
shares an item, you'll
probably want to put the buy
call to action, so that the
user knows that they can make
a purchase when they
click on that post.
If you have an invite share, so
like I want to have other
people join the service with me,
I might have the call to
action say join.
And there's a whole bunch
of other ones.
If you have a music app, you
might say that someone who
clicks on this button
is going to listen.
So all of those verbs are listed
here, so you can choose
which one you want.
But you'll make that decision in
your app, whereas this list
just makes it easy for the
user to do the sample.
XIANGTIAN DAI: OK.
Let's see what happens
when you actually
tap the Share button.
Whoops.
Share it.
Yep.
Here, the first thing you'll
do is to get a share view
instance by calling
GPP share, share
instance, share dialogue.
So this will give you a share
filter instance, which you can
fill in these parameters for
this share diagloue.
The first parameter you
could fill is the URL.
So your post contains the
content of web URL.
And so you can fill this URL in
so that our share dialogue
could render a preview for
this sys web page.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, and that
preview could have a picture,
title, description.
Kind of basic stuff, so that you
can actually see that in
the Google+ before you
click on the link.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Alternately, if
your share content, if the
content of the post does not
have a web presence, you can
also manually assemble the
title, description, and some
URL by what's called set
title description
some URL message here.
Now we come to the
deep link ID.
A deep link ID is a string that
can be passed directly to
your app so that when a user
taps on this post, she's
directed into this particular
state of view of your app.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So deep link
ID is just a string.
Developers get to completely
specify it.
What happens is when a user
create a share, developers
attach a deep link
ID to that share.
When a user clicks on that post
on a mobile device, iOS
or Android, they will be taken
to your app, and your app will
be given the deep link ID so
that the user can be taken
directly to where they should
be in that app.
So in the case of when you buy
something, you probably want
to take them to the item that
they were going to purchase.
And in the case that you were
listening to a song, you
probably want to take them
to that exact song.
XIANGTIAN DAI: That's right.
So with that set up, content
deep link ID here by setting
content deep link ID.
And that the next thing
is the pre-field text.
A pre-field text provides you
that good start before the
actual text content
of the post.
So the user does not have
to start from scratch.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, so
this is really cool.
You can pick a meaningful
message for that user and help
them get started with the share
message in the text, and
the user can always change it,
because they might start out
with, hey, come join
me in my app.
This is a lot of fun.
And then the user might change
it, and maybe plus mention
some of their friends, or do
anything else that they want
with the share.
XIANGTIAN DAI: And now we come
to the focus of today's talk,
the interactive post.
We make an interactive
post by setting the
call to action button.
This call to action button
consists of three parts.
A label, which is one of the
string, or actions that this
above, and the URL, which the
URL of this call to action
button, it will point to.
And then of course but the
deep link ID, which will
directly take the user
to your app.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, so this is
really the thing that makes
an interactive post.
The rest of it is all about
sharing on iOS, but right
here, this is where you get to
actually specify the label
that appears in the stream,
and this is what will make
your type of your share stand
out among others on Google+ so
that more people will
click on it.
Because they know what they're
going to do when
they hit that button.
XIANGTIAN DAI: That's right.
OK.
And then the last thing you'll
do is to [INAUDIBLE]
open, and the share dialogue
will be opened and waiting for
the user to actually finish the
composition and tap on the
post, the share button.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
XIANGTIAN DAI: OK, let's see
how this works again.
In action.
So I'm going to run a sample
app on the simulator.
So this is the main interface
on the Apple app.
Before the user can make an
interactive post, she'll need
to be signed in with Google.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So this is why
Google+ sign in unlocks an
interactive post.
So the user will need to go
through this consent flow and
agree to sign in
with your app.
And then once they've done
that, they can click on a
share button, which in
this case will be
an interactive share.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yeah.
That's [INAUDIBLE].
That's a bookmark.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
So a [INAUDIBLE] bookmark, and
this might make sense if your
app has topics or items
that users bookmark.
And so when they share this
topic out to Google+, they
think that others should be
bookmarking it as well.
XIANGTIAN DAI: That's right.
And the other share, let's just
put it as our developed
doc, and let's prefield
text with
welcome to Google+ platform.
And let's tap on share, and we
can see the share dialogue.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
So the things you'll see are the
pre-field text, welcome to
Google+ platform.
You see the preview,
which was generated
from the content URL.
And most importantly, you'll see
the call to action down at
the bottom, and it
says bookmark.
And this is what makes an
interactive post interactive.
You can click on that, and it
will be taken directly to the
app so you can bookmark
something.
Depending on how good you are
at picking that button, you
can actually drive a lot
more users to your app.
XIANGTIAN DAI: OK.
And the user will just tap
on share, and-- oops.
It's done.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
XIANGTIAN DAI: It has
stated success.
So this is just a simple app
simulator, and let's see how
our actual app works.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
So we're going to go over
to a real device,
instead of the simulator.
And so there are some
interactive posts in the
Google+ stream, and I
see this one here.
And it says there's
an unbreakable
self defense umbrella.
Well, I know everyone
wants one of these.
And that what I see on the
post is a Buy button.
And so this is the interactive
post part.
And if I see this in my stream,
then I think, maybe I
do want an unbreakable
umbrella.
I will click the Buy button,
because I know that I can
actually purchase it
on the other end.
When I click the Buy button,
I'm taken to the fancy app,
and I'm not just taken to the
app, but I'm actually taken
into the app, deep to where that
unbreakable self defence
umbrella exists.
And I can see the man standing
on the umbrella, and I can
also see how I can add
it to my cart.
So it's a very easy way
for me to get from
Google+ into an app.
And it's also a very easy way
for me to actually buy
something, if I wanted this.
So that's really powerful,
because developers at the
Fancy got to choose buy
as the call to action.
I mentioned that music apps
could say listen.
So if I click the Listen button,
I'd be taken to the
app, and then the music would
already start playing.
So it's a really nice experience
for users, and it's
really up to your creativity to
see how you can make your
apps better with interactive
posts.
So that's what we
wanted to demo.
I think that there are some
questions that people have
about interactive posts.
If you have any more, feel
free to leave those, of
course, on the Google+ event,
or on YouTube, and we'll be
sure to get to them.
The first comment on here is
do I have to choose between
interactive posts and
the original share?
So original type of share.
Yeah.
Xiangtian?
XIANGTIAN DAI: Sure.
Sure.
The interactive post has a super
set of functionalities
over original share, so that
it contains all of what
original share can do, plus
more, which is this call to
action button, which potentially
lets your app
stand out in the stream and
leads more users, more traffic
to your app.
Now of course, whether this call
to action button suits
your needs is dependant on
individual app developers.
So you may want to try it out
to see how it works for you.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
So you can choose that last
little bit where you add the
call to action is the place
where you decide whether you
want to use this or not.
Another common question here.
Currently the Share button
redirects users to Safari for
a mobile web share instead
of a native
Google+ share dialogue.
Is there a way to avoid this?
So unfortunately, the answer to
this is that right now, you
have to use Safari in order to
do the interactive post share.
But that's a good point.
We should try and get that into
the Share app, and we'll
work on it.
So, yeah.
That's a good question.
All right, yeah.
Thanks so much for
joining us today.
Everything we talked about is on
developers.google.com/plus.
If you have any further
questions, we have a pretty
good Google+ Developers'
community, and we're also on
Stack Overflow.
So if you have any questions
about interactive posts, the
platform in general, if you want
me to fix your computer,
that's probably not the
best place for it.
But just be sure to join us
next week as we talk more
about more topics.
So, thanks Xiangtian for
joining us today.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Thank
you, Chris, for
letting me join you.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
That was great.
Bye.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]